hi reject nation I'm Greg Alba no I'm
John Humphrey we're gonna watch a video
here from looper one of the best
channels ever the movie that
accidentally killed almost half of its
cast too bad the word killed in the
title yellow dollar bill signs shut this
channel down this is a topper war to
your video requests for a man named
Jason Dolan here goes nothing let's
check this out
the story of the 1956 film the conqueror
is among the most shameful in the
history of Hollywood the big budget
would be blockbuster featured an
epically miscast John Wayne at the 13th
century monger warlord Genghis Khan it's
not just like Genghis Khan had a
Southern drawl no that's bad enough the
worst part is a Conqueror nearly killed
hobbits cast one of the last films
produced by the famously eccentric
businessman Howard Hughes the Conqueror
was a critical laughingstock and the
commercial failure in his later years
huge apostle he bought up every print of
the film he could find and obsessively
watched it nearly every evening in his
private screening room why some
speculate it was out of guilt over the
decision to film the Conqueror in a
nuclear fallout zone yes Wow a conqueror
was filmed on location outside the dusty
sleepy town of st. George Utah which lay
about 100 miles downwind of the US
government's nuclear test zone in 1953
alone of the government around 11
nuclear tests they're assuring the
residents of st. George that there was
no danger from the radiation they were
wrong between 1954 film filmed in st.
George and 1981 no fewer than ninety one
of the production's 220 cast and crew
contracted some type of cancer abandoned
but doesn't include incidents of cancer
among family members who also spent the
summer on set at the time it was thought
the location was safe
so even Wade himself brought his sons
Patrick and Michael for an extended
visit both later developed cancer at one
point a Geiger counter was brought to
the set but it gave off so much noise
that Wayne assumed it was not
functioning but it wasn't and the cast
and crew Supergirl some of the effects
weights go start
armendariz developed kidney cancer in
1960 and took his own life in 1963 after
being given a terminal diagnosis that
same year director Dick Powell succumb
to cancerous lymphoma another of Wang's
co-stars veteran stage and screen
actress and four-time Academy Award
nominee Agnes Moorehead passed away from
uterine cancer in 1972 and Khan's love
interest Susan Hayward died of ammonia
brought on from complications due to
Prancer in 1975 as the Wain he received
a diagnosis of lung cancer in 1964 after
having one of his lungs and four ribs
removed he was declared cancer-free
and went on to star in several more
classic films including the Green Berets
and True Grit his final role in the 1976
Western The Shootist was an eerie
harbinger of things to come he portrayed
an aging gunfighter who engages in one
last campaign the frontier justice after
being told that his painful death from
cancer is imminent during a routine
Galba over for the 1979 surgeons found
the malignant tumor which forced them to
remove the jukes stomach when he died
six months later more toward 46 people
who worked on the conquerer die from
cancer or related illnesses and they
weren't alone a subsequent study
concluded that as many as eleven
thousand Americans I figure which some
believed to be ridiculously conservative
lost their lives as a result of cold
war-era nuclear testing since 1990 a
fund established by Congress has paid
out two billion dollars to residents are
the very fallout area where the
conquerer was filmed an area which
includes Saint George in which cancer
rates remain abnormally high in 2015 a
st. George residents and activists
Michelle Thomas a cancer survivor whose
mother died from the disease told The
Guardian it's gone into our DNA
I've lost counted the Friends of buried
I'm not patriotic my government lied to
me you have to forgive me if I don't
give a sh about John Wayne they rewrote
my DNA they only wrote my life by all
accounts a Hughes considered his choice
of location for the Conqueror's shoot to
be the worst mistake of his life to his
credit though it should be noted that
before selecting st. George as a
location he was worried about the
possibility of radiation danger from the
testing so he asked the government
Mackenzie Commission for advice their
answer they told him it would be
perfectly safe check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite films
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and to the bail so you don't
miss a single one I want to make movies
this is awesome to watch right after
you've finished a season of Chernobyl
radiation poisoning is hot right now
it's a hot topic
hahahaha hot it's good because you know
it's not oh that's my temperature
temperature yes and sexy wow talk about
some type of evil presence in the form
of science
god damn back then though would they
have known you know would they have
known that it's possible that it could
lead to all this it seems like Howard
Hughes was directly warned about it if
he had all this sort of guilt and
remorse towards the situation at hand so
they said the government said it was
safe to shoot there so I mean he
couldn't have been warned that way yeah
I mean aside from maybe the common sense
of just going on maybe we won't shoot
downwind from a nuclear testing site
because yeah this was decades ago so
might not have been enough scientific
evidence to back up that this is a
reality you know yeah I mean then they
said they even brought a Geiger counter
under the set and it was going nuts and
like that to me was the last drop I
don't know even if it was broken I would
go get a new counter at least because if
that thing's making hell annoys like
that would really jar me it makes me
really curious as to what they knew
about radiation at the time now what the
side effects could be what the proximity
restrictions are effort John Wayne
didn't exactly have the healthiest of
habits but he had to battle all kinds of
cancer to Hampton trails like everybody
on the second cancer yeah most people
seem like they just die from it John
Wayne and managed to survive it and then
it came back in a different form and now
he's on our wall he's on our wall what's
sad about this too is that you know it's
not even like a Ben Hur situation like
people died on that right or animals
died for sure like a lot of like
sacrifices were made but they got this
classic film out of it
where the conquerer has hail to be
looking up it's considered one of the
worst movie city you know of the decade
it's considered just terrible fail you
know even John Wayne me casting it is
controversial in it of itself especially
sad that not only all these people you
know give their lives to make this movie
that they were clearly they were
passionate about it's meant to be an
epic and then comes out to just be a
terrible movie just a complete misfire
it's exactly the same as Christian Bale
in Terminator Salvation it's exactly the
hunter purse not the same situation I
mean that movie looks like it was shot
in a nuclear testing site no I guess I
can also see why everyone was so
agitated on this a lot of tempers
running high yes it does add insult to
injury that such a terrible film also
had such terrible real-world
ramifications the woman at the end of
this really broke my heart where she
said like I'm not patriotic anymore you
know they said this was safe you rewrote
my DNA I've had to live with the
ramifications of these bad decisions I'm
sure there are fair few people for whom
Ben Hur is not a masterpiece no
definitely not her box office wise it
was fine Howard Hughes is so fascinating
to me I've seen the Aviator
oh yes that's all you need to know they
cover all this the first movie he did
yeah you hear about the crazy production
there and all the controversy around a
lot of his films he pushed it to the
limit I'm glad it was acknowledged that
he felt some remorse for this and I
guess is like an engineer and an
entrepreneur and and you know somebody
clearly interested in various types of
science I do wonder also I mean they
said that thing about him getting
clearance from the government or
whatever but I wonder how much he
himself would have known about these
kinds of things cuz bet he would have
known something well
Chernobyl season 2 here it comes period
piece get an anthology that's what they
should do every season should focus on a
new type of true radiation story yeah
now go in for that come on you know you
kind of want to watch it Chernobyl
season two you want to take on we're
just play joggers coppers well if you
guys like this video from looper you
should there are great channels
drive to them subscribe to the real
rejects please click that notification
bell check us out on patreon where we
got [ __ ] to offer you in return for
stuff
Jason Dolan I just wanted to say thank
you buddy
for requesting this well Jason came on
this channel recently he came on John
and I was a great experience drenched in
the holy juices of Jason Jason's juices
as I like to call him but there's a
bummer I missed it he had a barbecue on
Sunday and he was totally given out free
samples of Jason's juices and I didn't
get one yeah I mean I hear that contain
some radiation poisoning though so you
got to be a little mindful of the Jason
juices the whole screen writing pursuits
I know you have made a lot of progress
in the film that you got like a lot of
people really involved for I don't know
if I could say the title the project
yeah at some 9vb blood loss that's gonna
be a big thing but I hope you can it so
you can open up Jason's juices faces
juice is a perfect name